non ti vengono quindi non ho capito ma
non toccare un doppio no no no niente
capito ma ancora con le mani ok
i gendarmi franca siamo tutti quanti in
qui presenti perché stiamo per fare gli
auguri a gianluigi che fai compleanno
gianluigi non ex ante
ma dov'è il tuo fratello ragazzi manca
saverio quando gliene frega niente a
saverio quindi ragazzi tutti insieme
coordinati
tanti auguri a te
tanti auguri a tanti auguri a gianluigi
siamo completamente il ritardo c'è chi
gene che cosa brutta ma è morto dentro
ma ciò non ci sia qui che qui tanti
auguri ma sembra morto e parigi
tanti auguri ai grande bravi ragazzi con
la barba veramente bravissimi e dai
quando vuoi
tali viviamo si ragazzi qua proprio si
finisce mai non si finisce mai
entro venti tragica vita dei muri e
dell'inclusione ragazzi l'unica cosa che
ci è rimasta è unificare tra l'altro con
un look alla mio cugino gabriele fisico
da top le doti niente la cosa importante
però è che nessuno dica mai a jason
momoa che sa pure brava perché
altrimenti me lo ritrovo sotto casa e in
tempo da quarantena veramente non saprei
cosa fare non saprei come aprile mi
piacerebbe un po il cuore a di linda
caro non ti posso aprire ci vediamo
un'altra volta quando finisce l'embargo
pd hanno come viene
era venerdì ser certo momo adesso anche
cucina del pame ad alzarmi ogni pc a
parte è appena arrivato un messaggio un
ragazzo e si chiama dottor panda mi ha
dato un altro metodo per fare il nuovo
in camicia lista pro a tutti
ora mi farò una colazione un brunch un
brunch un brunch con l'uovo in camicia
ha fatto come dice di fare questo
ragazzo per tempo il brano quanto mi
piace dire brunch di riuscire a zoomare
sulla bocca brown ma prima che guglielmo
posto ammorbarci col suo ennesimo uovo
in camicia complimenti per l'originalita
ragazzo vi faccio vedere il tumore o nel
quale stiamo vivendo
vi dico solo che la mia anima è più
ordinata allora l'acqua bolle mi ha
detto di usare questo purtroppo mi
vedete ciò non ha una terza mano quindi
non so come farò ma cercherò di fare
tutto quanto in diretta quindi prendo
dell'acqua
la protezione qui non secondi non
vediamo se ci portò si vabbè se uscendo
dell'acqua sti cavoli poi tanto si
asciugherà tutto quanto che cazzo
ammesso lavora dentro a faccia partire
tre lilu di lo devo tipo mezzo ottenere
immerso così come succede pre cantare
vittoria però signori si scola un nome è
attaccato ma no ma no non ci credo bene
e adesso che ancora una volta ha fallito
vi chiederei gentilmente di smettere di
dargli consigli perché poi li segue al
contrario di quelli che ti do in amore
ragazzi ringrazio di cuore magari leggo
e chiedo scusa se non rispondo a tutti i
miei occhi vedo i consigli su come fare
luogo in camicia
molti di questi due già fatti non viene
non viene non viene proverò a farne
altri tentativi però come giustamente li
state facendo notare le sto sparando
tipo un botto di quota in questo periodo
non so cosa succede a chi mangia troppo
vago cerchino già troppo magari questo
le è venuta in mente un'idea mia nonna
deve fare una videochiamata con dei suoi
amici di chiesa su quel programma dove
abbiamo festeggiato con mio fratello
quindi stavo pensando di metterle uno
sfondo inerente all'argomento ecco
questo qui non è male immaginatevi la
nonna qui in così è dietro a questa
immagine ci vediamo a brevissimo
mi raccomando poi salutare
[Musica]
ma perché niente ragazzi sono solo io ma
queste giornate veramente paul annuncia
io mi sveglio la mattina faccio
colazione è già notte onda dormire
confezionate
[Musica]
ho deciso che questa settimana la
passione all insegna dell opulenza e
quindi sto facendo anche io come si
chiamano degli aperitivi con lavinia
saluta la v ai cinque guardano sbatto
contro il telefono com'è andata la
giornata oggi io ho fatto un sacco di
cose soprattutto ha fatto da vie d'acqua
una cosa che ho notato è che il fisico
da covip mi sta aiutando nella vita
reale cioè è presente il caffè dice
sempre devi essere una garanzia delle
combatte il 9.81 della gravità io oggi
ho fatto la spesa
me la sono portata senza problemi l
altro giorno a gallo ha chiamato e mi ha
detto che anche quando non fa il culo
nadir ust
ti prego dammi una piccola scheda di
critica io vi faccio un culo né ad
illustrare al ragazzo il cui in fiamme
ci potrà cuocere no io se non stessi in
quarantena sarei tiratissimo ma lui
riesce a contrastare tutto una miss
romagna in questi giorni
pian piano entro fine quarantena io
senza maglietta dovrò fare qualcosa
cioè tipo sexy tipo tipo tronista tipo
uomo oggetto bravo promesse lo giuro non
giuro stai giocando davanti a tutti a
tutti quanti non me ne pento ma cosa
volo sto girando un video spaccata sì mi
sono fatto subito finito l'allenamento
scamorza e uova e poi adesso mi sto
facendo un bel vino bianco e della
tartare di carne richiamo per dirti che
ho promesso alla linea che prima della
fine della quarantena io farò fisico la
tua vita senza maglietta come fai tu che
sei sempre senza maglietta molto celere
addominali ma veramente questa è una
cosa che hai detto è il professor tutti
dalla prima puntata infatti che tu hai
nel senso che ho detto che prima della
fine lo farò al cioccolato che tira
subito di sì cioè ci piango sopra mela
magno dice così la morbidì sco dove devo
accompagnare a barcone che mi butto le
sotto fa abbassare il senso di sazietà
quindi kg cia sfollati ancora di più
grazie abbiamo è sempre bello parlarti
senti scusa non prende bene il telefono
ci sentiamo di tonino bianco dello
stupro di biliardo sguardo freddo e
anche di una cantina speciale tornare
alle mie cose
ok tornano le due cose ciao gancia e
mezzanotte e mezza e ho fame e quindi ho
deciso di prepararmi scusatemi un po
sporco no erano solo le mie intenzioni
scherzi a parte ha deciso di preparare
la torta in tazza anche è quella lì che
forse sicuramente avete visto questa
domenica quindi se volete vedere la
ricetta cliccate sul link che comparirà
non so perché vi stiamo facendo un
doppione assi la cosa che mi piace e che
tardissimo e quindi molto probabilmente
girerò la ricetta la ricetta
la ricetta di domenica tardissimo perché
sennò domani il povero enrico il povero
gianmarco non avranno roba da montare
kendall seconda guardate quanto è bella
con la mano che la tiene era fa passare
le dita in maniera sensuale ed al quale
un gioco di luci
ricordiamoci questa sua sorella dello
smesso di fare una striscia di balcone
però questo non lasciare qui eccola ma
cresciuto il basilico la macchinetta
andata tutta bruciata squagliato tutta
la macchinetta che vuol dire sia
nominata si è sciolto
[Risate]
[Musica]
allora ragazzi siamo di fronte
all'evento nazionale
ho ricevuto una sfida attiva 20 da kg
ricevuto dal fratello della ragazza di
gianluigi e da gianluigi stesso che
stanno passando la quarantena nella
stessa abitazione loro due giocheranno
contro di me action
così gli faccio allora siamo pronti la
sfida sta per cominciare l'evento più
atteso d'italia se devo fare una piccola
introduzione posso dire che alessandro è
un gran giocatore ha già abbastanza una
sega quindi dovrebbero compensarsi io
sono un veterano di questo gioco
un'esperienza decennale dovrei scrutarla
teoricamente ragazzi siamo stati sfidati
da martino auto pronto in questa partita
e mi eccezionale di fifa 2020 40
io è predator giocatore professionista
di questo gioco contro marchino io pippa
colossale ma ci si abbia falco ha
cominciato a milano
l'attimo già messo le mani fa che
caproni guardate che fair play mail
oppure la palla c'è o ma che squadra
abbiamo sensibile un addio rimangiare sa
niente ma niente da fare
3 va 3 ma occhio al contropiede occhio
al contropiede box of options o no
eccola quindi cristiano ronaldo e del
rumore che non c'è logica del manchester
davanti alla nazione intera guarda che
figura al sesto minuto che figura da
capogiro per ora li teniamo senza
problemi
[Applauso]
e marty dovuto marchi voluto che ho
trovato ti ho visto un po migliorata
sensazionale ragazzino tienilo tienilo
[Applauso]
mamma mia
21 piemonte calcio ai azione burkina
crossato perché macro stato massa
stagione ed ha tirato va bene certo dopo
mezz'ora di partire gli anelli ci prendi
la mamma mia che miseria primo tempo
fine primo tempo ragazzi della 1 per
marchino oddio cristiano ronaldo che a
chiave occhio che frena portiere
mammamia da farsi si salvano solo lo
tengo non è un in palla come si stanno
salvando pietro capitolo respira respira
è completamente breve
[Applauso]
circolo non sbaglia beh è un reato dopo
partita
cristiano ronaldo ragazzi che dire
abbiamo perso
queste sono facce da chi ha perso
l'amarezza della sconfitta fregato
secondo me in un altro episodio si è
piaciuto possiamo fare una linea
fateci sapere se volete un altresì
proprio episodio bravo esatto marchino
detto questo [ __ ] alla prossima
ciao ciao il prossimo episodio
no no ti prego di voler smettere di far
mio figlio di brevi sono termini juntas
degli abati prego ti prego dai smettila